[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sap versus heide
gibt ein leckeres hauptgericht und zwar
werde ich lag zubereiten mit einer
avocado basar und naturreis dessen
gewicht was ist wirklich sehr gerne ist
es vor allem lachsfilet sich super gerne
und die zutaten sie wirklich super
einfach es ist schnelles rezept das
heißt innerhalb von 15 minuten etwa
steht euer fertiges gericht schon auf
dem tisch
und weil es eben so super einfach und
schnell geht's gleich weil die für taten
ich habe ich 150 gramm naturreis das ist
eine tasse dann brauche ich zweieinhalb
tassen wasser habe ich zwei raketen die
jeweils etwa 200 gramm und für die
avocado walser brauche ich ein bisschen
olivenöl etwa einem teelöffel zwei reife
avocados mit knoblauchzehe
cocktailtomaten 100 gramm eine zitrone
seiten verlassen
ich fange jetzt zuerst einmal mit dem
reis an der hat sie zeit von 10 minuten
da kommt jetzt hier in einen topf
reinhard tassen wasser mit dazu da kommt
jetzt noch eine prise salz mit rein
die könnt ihr weg lassen aber ich mag es
gern wenn ein bisschen salz im reich ist
jetzt lass ich das aufkochen stellte an
dem herr auch mittlere stufe und dann
kann bereits einfach nur noch sehen gibt
einen tropfen olivenöl einfach in der
beschichtete pfanne die erhöht sich
jetzt auf mittel hoher hitze und weiß
jetzt dass laxey
da war ich ganz groß und kann in der
zwischenzeit eigentlich schon mal die
avocado halbieren und den kern heraus
nehmen
[Musik]
das lachsfilet kombizange nicht auf die
hautseite und darf selbst bei mittlerer
hitze etwa 45 minuten braten
sie sind eine richtig schöne gruppe
gebildet hat und sobald diese kruste
gebildet hat können wir dann das relais
um sein
die branche schätzt für die avocado sie
werde ich jetzt sehr einschneidend war
nur ganz leicht so dass die schale nicht
zerstört wird und so entstehen dann
diese kleinen würfeln
[Musik]
mit einem lasso kann man die dann super
einfach auslösen
der richter könne es einfach runter gebe
ich nach dem saft der zitrone mittleren
avocados schneider aus zwei scheiben
extremisten
[Musik]
knoblauchzehen fein mir dass du wirst
das ganze dann mit salz pfeffer und im
restlichen olivenöl
[Musik]
da kommen die halbierten formate meter
hoch werden sie nur noch auf den laster
worten mit der laxen in krostitz trinken
um
die zweite vorschreiben 3 inso brauche
jetzt auch noch mal etwa zwei bis drei
minuten
[Musik]
jetzt ist das essen fertig und sagen
einfach schneller als die polizei
erlaubt das schnelle aus der hand nimmt
hat immer noch die kinder ab und lametta
seite hier lag oder lachsfilet hier
haben wir avocado und bin raus und ich
würde es noch waren extra bietet einfach
für euch aber farbe geht immer gorka
molis tauchrobotern im prinzip ist eine
kommune so eben nicht betrifft sondern
schön gewürfelt
es ist auch gerne morgens auf brot
superlecker vor allem mit bissen
knoblauch und zitrone und fifa sehr
lecker jetzt noch den fragen die partie
ist auch darüber gerne frisch vom ihre
auch sehr gerne vor allem lack mit einer
tipps aus
ich bin habe ich noch gewürze und salz
und pfeffer und beim reis mach ich das
wenn er noch ein bisschen witz beste ist
und einfach nicht so matschig ins le
bris wird deswegen mag ich naturreis vor
allem sehr gerne und er ist auch super
gesund den wo wir jetzt nicht vor der
blamage einem hals stecken
dass es jetzt gleich in ruhe hinter der
kamera ohne dass er dabei zuschaut
und weil es ja auch lust bekommen hat
auch die zweckeler rezept seht ihr
deswegen problem von der firma dann geht
oft fällig - da steht noch mal das
rezept das ist wirklich super einfach
können wir ganz einfach noch das schule
oder nach der arbeit zu bereiten und hab
ihn nicht einmal 15 minuten einen weg
verständigt also viel spaß und nach
macht und bis zum nächsten mal
übrigens fabrizieren bisschen sind auch
gekocht mittwoch war der heinrich ein
bisschen nach
auch mental
[Musik]
mehr
u